direction l'italie pays le plus durement
frappé par cette pandémie plus de 18000
personnes sont décédées ducobu 19
l italien a enregistré hier 6 124
nouveaux décès conséquence les italiens
resteront confinées jusqu'au 3 mai
annonce du gouvernement en première
ligne dans cette crise les personnels de
santé depuis le début de l'épidémie une
centaine de médecins sont décédés après
avoir été contaminés et jordi de mousse
ils sont en première ligne face au co
vie 19 en italie pays européens qui
comptent le plus grand nombre de morts
le personnel soignant payent un lourd
tribut depuis le début de l'épidémie
une centaine de docteurs sont décédés du
coronavirus sur place leurs confrères
dénonce le peu d'équipement de
protection mises à leur disposition nos
croyant que le manque d'équipements de
protection individuelle médical et les
problèmes d'approvisionnement sont sans
aucun doute liés aux taux d'infection
élevé et à certains des décès que nous
avons constaté depuis début mars
certains médecins italiens ne cesse
d'alerter notamment sur le manque de
masque une situation qui commence à
peine à s'améliorer
le problème du manque d'équipements de
protection individuelle est également un
problème au niveau institutionnel
provoqué par un tsunami de cas qui nous
a frappés a tout bouleversé
nous nous sommes retrouvés en état de
guerre munis d'armes inadéquate
notamment un nombre limité de masques
progressivement les masques deviennent
disponibles
par ailleurs à la place des masques
chirurgicaux les gens pourraient porter
des écharpes ou utiliser d'autres choses
afin de réduire l'émission de
gouttelettes
certes cette alternative serait moins
efficace par rapport aux masques
chirurgicaux mais elle peut être
utilisée
cela doit nous motiver à maintenir cette
distanciation sociale comme dans de
nombreux pays le personnel soignant ne
compte pas ses heures
mais en plus de soigner les malades ils
passent énormément de temps à s'équiper
et à ceux des contaminés
nous avons estimé que pour un travail de
7 heures environ 40 50 minutes sont
utilisés rien que pour l'habillage
s'étonner tel coin tollé ouardane
d'eycheil lavables gelé les mains agnel
pour ce qui est du lavage des mains et
la décontamination des mains on peut
parler de 60 75 minutes par jour
toujours lourdement touché l'italie
continue de recevoir de l'aide venus du
monde entier
ce mercredi un avion de l'armée de l'air
du qatar est arrivé avec du matériel
pour construire deux hôpitaux de
campagne à rome et à vérone